ليست مجرد ان نزهه عاديه لطفل يلهو على
دراجته الهوائيه بل هي رحله زكريا اليوميه
لا الى مدرسته بل الى ورشه العمل
يتحمل اللاجئ السوري الذي لم يتجاوز عمره
13 ربيعا مشقه العمل ليجن الفتات وعلى
يديه الصغيرتين حفرت ساعات العمل الطويله
ندوبا وتركت في قلبه غصه
من عمر تسعه سنين صرت اشتغل
وعملت عروس
سبعه للخمسه سته
يوميات من مقاس الوجوه
هؤلاء الاطفال السوريون وجدوا فرصه تعليم
حرم منها الاف اخرون اما المدرسه التي
تحتضنهم فتقاوم تحديات الازمه وتواجه خطر
اقفال ابوابها امام مئات اللاجئين معرضين
نروح لاي مطرح يعني معرضين ايه بيوم
الايام انه المدرسه تقفل ابوابها اذا بقيت
الازمه الاقتصاديه على ما هي عليه
يا هيمونا على وجوههم المنهكه طوال اليوم
حملتهم رياح الحرب الى بلاد يتارجح فيها
مستقبلهم بين السيء والاسوا
ذلك ان كثيرا منهم ارغم على ترك مقاعد
الدراسه بفعل الازمه الاقتصاديه في ما
ارتفعت نسبه الاميين بينهم وهو ما ينبئ
وفق المنظمات الدوليه بتشكل جيل الامي
كامل في صفوف اللاجئين السوريين
والدول المنحه بزياده الاستثمار
بنظام الدراسي لمنعه من انهيار لبنان
من الازمات التي يشهدها لبنان بعد نجاته
من اكون الحرب في سوريا
يدفعوا الاطفال السوريون في لبنان ضريبه
اللجوء وما ينجم عنه من تبعات مريره
فهؤلاء حرموا منذ ولادتهم من ابسط حقوقهم
لا سيما التعليم ما دفع المنظمات الاهليه
للتحذير من مخاطر تشكل جيل الامين نتيجه
قصور السياسات عم دمجهم تربويه كارمن
الجزيره البقاع شرقيه لبنان